après avoir parlé de l'avenir de la
haute couture on va parler maintenant du
passé de jean paul gaultier
alors jean paul vous est né en 1952
arcueil
non je raconte en fait je vais raconter
l'enfance de jean paul gaultier parce
que vous avez jamais renier ni votre
enfant si votre classe sociale ni mot
ami de l'époque du collège donc être
quelqu'un de grande fidélité
alors parents modestes un père comptable
mère caissière au restaurant de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations c'est
vrai qu'il s'est plaint malgré tout est
alors éducation très tolérante par
exemple un jour il voit la télévision
devine qui vient dîner ce soir avec
sidney poitier qu est l histoire d'un
noir sidney poitier poser ni blanche à
l'époque sans les années cette année
dans les années 50 ses choix à l'époque
est alors gène soldes si vous dites à
vos parents ainsi j'épouse et une noire
qu'est ce que vous diriez ma mère m'a
dit écoute si tu les aimes à la parfait
comme ça et là j'ai mais si tu veut nous
tuer qu'est ce qui te semble bien mais
c'est vous parce que voilà c'est pour
l'époque et pour disent ils à la classe
sociale à laquelle vous étiez c'était
quand même très rare par exemple quand
nos parents vous leur dites que vous
êtes homosexuel
bah si tu le lem ya pas de problème
c'est pas grave ce soit un garçon c'est
à dire que des années après elle a
continué à avoir la même attitude que
voilà ses repères les vidéos c'est quand
votre grand mère vous a offert un livre
sur l'homosexualité
se douter de quelque chose passe sur
l'homosexualité est une histoire où il y
avait quelque chose qui se passait comme
ça je comprenais pas trop très bien
c'est le terme et les trois en un mot
tout ça m'a paru bizarre et tout elle
m'a dit tu sais quoi de très gentil avec
eux à balard la suite je suis devenu
très gentil très très très gentil avec
des militants non plus dans les votes
grand mère c'est comme madonna avait les
deux héroïnes de votre vie
non poway c'est assez génial parce
qu'elle m'a donné confiance en moi là
bon si ça c'est à dire que je crois que
c'est assez génial quand même donné la
chance d'être aimée quand on est gamin
quoi ça c'est je vois ça donne après une
espèce de force et de chiba c'est
merveilleux alors votre grand mère était
couturière elle était voyante elle tirer
les cartes et donner des conseils de
beauté de relookage et vous essayez vos
talents de coloriste sur elle voilà j'ai
essayé comme sur mon amour c'est tout je
lui teignant les cheveux quelques fois
en bleu asim je vais c'est trop
longtemps je vous l un des prises avant
même temps du col de venir aux pratiques
punk avant l'heure encore après et c'est
chez elle que vous découvrez le corset
et jean paul gaultier une phrase sur le
corps c'est que je vais citer le corset
c'est une machinerie saumon balle est né
aulas et orthopédiques fascinant moi je
trouve que c'est une description du
corps sikhs et définitive
elle vous racontez votre grand mère
quand on met le corps c'est quand on
était elle avait pratiqué l messe le
corse est destiné à rétrécir la taille
donc aussi à soutenir quelque fois la
colonne vertébrale est enfin là sur un
plan esthétique
donc elle prenait un verre de vinaigre
le buvaient et à ce moment là elle avait
une contraction quand ça rentrait donc
dans l'estomac et à ce moment là il
fallait serrer le l'objet la taupe est
dit
donc la taille après étaient tous deux
filles c'est la dimension sado maso où
et comment et du corps c'est totalement
entame en brique et fascinant et alors
20 ans après vous essayer une robe qui
est un corset mais qui risque à terre et
dans un sens il fallait être un petit
peu en effet sado maso pour le porter
puisque du fait qu'il était entièrement
là parce que je les fais vraiment comme
un vrai pur et dur donc je les fais
jusqu'à terre et là c'est jusqu'à telle
conclusion impossible de faire pipi
voilà donc la personne qui la porte et
marie christiane marek et qui commet
elle est restée n'a absolument rien bu
rien fait et où elle pouvait que bouger
comme ça difficilement puisque en plus
était entravé
alors votre vote madeleine c'est le
parfum dire ici la poudre de riz de
votre grand-mère l'honneur du châtelet
enfin meetic baigner dans tout cet
univers comme ça des années quoi 50 64
est alors votre grand mère vous dit tout
ce que je fais je le lui doit
si vous voulez comme elle était avec ses
clientes et quelle est leur donner les
conseils des conseils aussi bien
vous devriez peut-être changer de
coiffure alors tirer les cartes vous
devriez changer de coiffure comme ça
vous dessert est mieux avec votre main
donc moi je prenais comment je voyais en
fin de compte l'importance de la lure
par rapport à ce que ça pouvait avoir
comme conséquences sur la vue donc
l'importance du paraître
alors autres influences évidemment dim
dam dom l'émission de daisy de galard
mais c'est extraordinaire et émission
qui n'est jamais été égalé par la suite
les émissions aussi sur la haute couture
de jean christophe averty enfin c'est
l'époque où la tv aurait pu devenir un
art et il y aurait eu des télés ascom ya
des cinéastes
heureusement que ça voulait dire
exactement dim dam dom wiedemann mode
demo alors une mine mana c'est déjà du
verlan est influencé aussi par la presse
les coûts de la mode au jardin des modes
elle influencé par les folies bergères
aussi s'accommoder de ces petits
découper des plumeaux voilà pour en
faire une revue stea que c'était mon
tour ce qui devenait la line renaud la
mick micheyl et faisait la revue à ma
grand mère cet ours en peluche
vous lui avez fait des faux seins déjà
voilà les premiers avant madonna
ouais c'est à dire les c'était des cônes
déconne déjà en papier journal et voilà
et je suis italien je faisais aussi
subir tous les sévices de l'époque
s'appelait nana normal pour un ours si
vous êtes joli dessin d'ailleurs parce
que je me voyais pas à l'époque ne
visaient pas les hommes mais cet ours il
est toujours dans votre bureau dans une
boîte et puis alors aussi de votre
influence c'est aussi paris ou venus en
deux chevaux le samedi après-midi quoi
puis le paris des touristes japonais
quoi le paris des cartes postales
j'adore way à 18 ans vont entrer chez
cardin comme assistant votre mère vous
accompagne moi parce que j'étais trop
timide c'est le jour de mon anniversaire
à 12h15 d'un t'attends pas y aller tout
seul donc elle est là et puis jouer
monsieur cardin qui m'engagent tout de
suite ça c'est assez génial parce que le
fait qu'ils manga je sens que j'ai fait
aucune école de mode ça prouvera ça m'a
ouvert quand même un petit peu l'esprit
oui hélas jean paul gaultier commence à
mélanger à métisser avec une approche un
peu on pourrait dire de stylistes
puisque de ça vous fait grâce aux
journalistes en fin de mois parce que
quand j'étais petit donc comme j'ai pas
fait d'école de mode je regardais et je
lisais surtout ce qu'est ce qu'ils
écrivaient les journalistes et quelques
fois le montrait ben oui ce vêtement là
vous pouvez le porter de telle ou telle
façon mélangés par exemple une
combinaison de mes cannes
avec des talons aiguille les bijoux en
strass et je trouvais ça aussi
intéressant qu'en fin de compte que les
créations de couturiers
je trouvais aussi intéressante mais ça
aussi ça me trouve ça presque mieux je
quitte extraordinaire avec gauthier
c'est que maintenant quand tu vois dans
la rue une fille qui a un blouson de
cuir un tut tut danseuses et des tennis
bah c'est lui messi c'est pourtant
aujourd'hui c'est devenu quelque chose
de très très courant c'est pas toujours
lui d'effacer des personnels 138 me sens
aussi ce qu'on peut dire qu'on peut dire
pour résumer le travail de jean paul
gaultier
si vous avez fait avec la mode ce qu'ont
fait les musiciens que s'emplit voile ça
mais ça n'est pas que ça je connais jean
paul lafay aussi la musique